hegemony yah-tchi sunrise here on Sky
News it is 6:35 breaking news to bring
you a while you were watching adverts
Sky DS petition to establish an
independence debates commission at
general elections has just passed
100,000 signatures now that means the
matter has to be considered for debate
in Parliament this is after we launched
this campaign back in September in a
moment we'll find out what the next
stage is but first here's Sky's Louis
Goodell the next stage of sky News's
campaign to make general election
debates happen has been reached over
100,000 people have signed a petition on
Parliament's website to call for an
independent commission to set up
organise and run debates between
political leaders at each and every
general election I want to say a big
thank you to all of those who have
signed the petition and I urge the
petition committee to make sure that
this petition for an independent
commission is debated in the House of
Commons so what happens next
now our petition for an independent
debates commission has reached a
required number of signatures it will be
considered for debate by the committee
made up of 11 MPs from labour the
Conservatives and the SNP debates that
then organize won't take place in the
Commons chamber itself but in a separate
debating room Westminster Hall in
addition a government minister will be
obliged to respond
so far they've said it's a matter for
political parties to resolve please
welcome David Cameron Nick Clegg and
Gordon Brown election debates between
leaders are commonplace in most other
Western democracies but in Britain
they've only happened in for once in
2010 in 2015 David Cameron insisted on
their dilution and in 2017 Theresa May
point-blank refused there's an excellent
focus I'll support the petition soon as
I get the opportunity to sign it I will
some politicians want to see that
restored and a backing Sky's campaign
it's absolutely essential I think the
sky deserve a lot of credit for pushing
this very hard and the last election was
absolute travesty we didn't have a
proper exchange of views
the economic promises were completely
unconstitutional so having a proper
debate and I'm certainly as a little cat
very much up for being part of they can
be very difficult to visit future
general elections without leaders
debates happening last time well and I
think people noticed it and I think
people there were debates but they
weren't necessarily in the way that they
have been before and I think that
actually that did come up on the
doorsteps so I don't think party leaders
are gonna want that to be an issue
they're gonna have to answer questions
about in the future
in America a commission like the one
Sky's proposing has been in place for
decades resulting in debates every
election year since 1976
but in Britain Prime Minister's in
historically done all they can to get
out of them including you though with
Theresa May backing the idea of a brexit
debate with Jeremy Corbyn and with the
issue being debated in Parliament
perhaps next time it will be much harder
the prime minister of the day to get out
of them it says much about the ability
of politicians to set the terms of our
democracy that these debates haven't
taken place regularly before now by
taking it out of the horse race between
the politicians and the broadcaster's it
might be the only thing to circumscribe
that ability permanently Lewis Caroll's
can use Westminster